laurent wauquiez qui est candidat à la
présidence des républicains semblent
profiter de cette séquence pour lui
accélérer avoir un discours de plus en
plus forts de plus en plus offensif
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire contre
emmanuel macron vous vous souvenez de
ces déclarations sont laquelle le
président de la république n'aurait pas
l'amour charnel de la france
est ce que c'est la bonne stratégie j'ai
eu 20 traube de profiter que mélenchon
est dans un trou d'air marine le pen
inaudible pour pour parler de plus en
plus fort laurent wauquiez le seul
candidat qui a une chance de gagner une
élection interne à la droite
en gros et républicains en gros il peut
dire à peu près n'importe quoi ses
adversaires aussi respectable soit ils
sont tellement peu connues est allé aux
missions le fond il a raison inconnue si
fort contre le président
c'est une séquence c'est une ses cordes
dir dit oui ni non
oui ça veut dire ni oui ni non moi
j'aurais tendance à dire que le fait que
marine le pen n'arrive pas à remonter la
pente depuis son échec de la
présidentielle et que
mélenchon est échoué dans ses tentatives
d'incarner la positio position à lui
tout seul devrait permettre à laurent
wauquiez d'élargir son public et de ne
pas s'adresser à sa base électorale au
sens étroit du terme il n'a pas choisi
comme ça en fait ils mènent une campagne
zéro risque entré les mains qui trouvent
que